[LASER SHOTS]
Come on, Wolverine.
Let's go.
Eat dirt, Cyclops.
X-Men don't cut and run.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's up, everyone.
This is "Disney+ Deets,"
where we break down everything
you need to know
about your favorite
Disney+ movies and series.
I'm Kenneth.
MARCELLUS: And I'm Marcellus.
And not to toot our own
horns, but we're pretty
much the biggest
Disney+ fans out there.
No, let's do it.
Toot toot, beep beep,
that's right.
Let's get into it.
KENNETH: 12-year-old Kenneth
is (SINGSONG) excited.
Today's video is about
one of our favorite
super hero shows of all time,
"X-Men: The Animated Series."
Let's take it all the way
back to 1963 when Marvel
all-stars Jack Kirby and Stan
Lee created the first "X-Men"
comic book.
Originally, the
characters were teenagers
in identical blue uniforms
and their dialogue
was all quips and wisecracks.
In 1975, Marvel decided
to reimagine the X-Men
as a more international team.
MARCELLUS: Yes.
And you know what, Ken?
Diversity is key.
Writer Len Wein and
artist Dave Cockrum
came up with, among others--
Wolverine, who's Canadian,
and our favorite mistress
of the elements from
Northern Africa, Storm.
KENNETH: But this wasn't
just a new team roster.
It set a whole new
tone for the series.
The heroes were adults with
real relatable problems.
MARCELLUS: And I
just love how they
interacted with each other.
I wanted to like, sit
and chill with them
and just talk about stuff--
KENNETH: Right.
MARCELLUS: --that was going on.
MARCELLUS: What was
the next mission?
KENNETH: Exactly.
President of Fox
Kids Margaret Loesch
was an early fan of the comics
and thought the X-Men would be
perfect for an animated series.
So perfect in fact that Loesch
told her boss if "X-Men:
The Animated Series" doesn't
succeed, you can fire me.
MARCELLUS: That's commitment.
Putting it all on the line.
KENNETH: Once the series
got the green light in 1992,
Marvel and Fox agreed
to a core team.
Along with Wolverine,
Jubilee, and Storm,
they added Cyclops,
Rogue, and Gambit.
Professor Xavier, Jean Grey,
and Beast rounded out the squad.
Here we go.
Who is this?
It is (SINGSONG) Magneto!
MARCELLUS: Oh, I love Magneto.
KENNETH: One of the best
villains of all time!
MARCELLUS: On the
count of three,
say your favorite
X-Men character.
1, 2, 3--
BOTH: Storm!
MARCELLUS: Jinx.
According to creative
executive Sydney Iwanter,
it was important to focus
on these characters'
real emotional weaknesses.
KENNETH: Well, here's
the thing, they
just wanted typical
super hero vulnerabilities.
We're talking about Rogue
not being able to touch
anyone without consequences--
MARCELLUS: Oh, absolutely.
KENNETH: --Storm dealing
with being orphaned,
and even Wolverine dealing
with unrequited love.
MARCELLUS: Oh, let's talk
about the love triangle--
KENNETH: Oh, my.
MARCELLUS: --that is Cyclops,
Wolverine, and Jean Grey.
And poor Wolverine, he was
supposed to be at the wedding.
But he is mad because he is
in love with his frenemy's
wife, Jean Grey.
We all love Jean Grey.
KENNETH: I feel like
Jean Grey was the glue.
MARCELLUS: She was.
KENNETH: She would always
come in and kind of just
make sure she was the
referee for everybody.
I can sense his feelings.
They seem genuine.
KENNETH: Just like Wolverine
that we see right here,
I used to put forks
between my fingers.
MARCELLUS: Yes!
Yes!
I thought I was the only one.
I had my mamma's butter knife.
KENNETH: Yes.
MARCELLUS: And I was
walking around the house
thinking I was Wolverine.
"Boy, if you don't put
my butter knife back
in that drawer!"
KENNETH: I just
need pictures of you
in all your makeshift
X-Men costumes.
And we can't forget
about my boy Morph.
He was only supposed
to be in one episode.
But Fox had a focus group
with a couple hundred kids.
And they voted for Morph
as their favorite mutant,
resurrected by popular demand.
MARCELLUS: The first season
had one continuous storyline.
But due to animation
delays, season
two's episodes were created
to stand on their own.
So if one episode
wasn't finished on time,
another could be
shown in its place.
KENNETH: Networks at the
time didn't think kids could
follow complicated storylines.
The series' writing
team disagreed, which
was definitely the right call.
And on behalf of kids
everywhere, we thank you.
MARCELLUS: Director
Larry Houston,
who was also the very
first Black Saturday
morning storyboard artist
to be hired in Hollywood,
was a big fan of legendary
comic book artist Jim Lee.
Lee's X-Men
costume designs
varied between characters,
but shared similar colors
and overall style, and therefore
inspired the look for the show.
KENNETH: We love to see it.
And speaking of making some
changes in Hollywood, Houston
and showrunner Eric Lewald
had a whole new approach
to casting the series.
The first batch of audition
tapes they received
were all too cartoonish.
MARCELLUS: Voice
actors at the time
weren't used to playing
it straight, especially
for a Saturday morning cartoon.
So they ended up bringing in
serious theater actors from
Toronto to voice their X-Men.
KENNETH: And these
actors brought
a gravitas and a grounding and
a realness to each character.
MARCELLUS: It was just
so amazing to hear it.
KENNETH: According to George
Buza, who voiced Beast,
the cast had to record all
of their dialogue lines first
because their voices would be
so worn out after doing battle
noises-- like this, Marcellus--
BOTH: [GRUNTING]
[LAUGHTER]
MARCELLUS: Still, all that
vocal strain paid off.
KENNETH: Before this
cartoon came out,
we didn't know how these
characters sounded.
MARCELLUS: We did not, we
definitely did not.
KENNETH: They were
only on paper.
So this is the first
time for us as fans
of the comic books to
actually hear the voice
of our favorite characters.
MARCELLUS: And we loved it.
The series packed so much
story into 22 minutes,
way more than other
animated shows at the time.
KENNETH: With 40-page scripts
consisting of 400 to 500 shots,
it took more than
30,000 animated frames
to make a single episode--
totally unheard of
for a kids cartoon.
MARCELLUS: This was way
before computer animation.
So every single one of those
frames was painted by hand.
KENNETH: Ooh, my hands are
cramping up just thinking
about all that painting.
MARCELLUS: And what
about the cameos
from the other Marvel heroes?
We got Captain
America right here,
who was already a big deal.
Hello, headline
news, we got X-Men.
And then you turn around,
and we got new people?
Ken, I was just starstruck.
KENNETH: We have to shout out
Eric Lewald and Julia Lewald.
We found their book,
"X-Men: The Art and Making
of the Animated
Series," super helpful
when making this episode.
If you're a fan of the
series, you'll love that book.
Make sure you check it out.
And that's our show for today.
MARCELLUS: Be sure
to like, subscribe,
and check out "X-Men:
The Animated Series,"
now streaming on Disney+.
KENNETH: Take care of
yourselves and the planet and.
We'll see you next time.
Marcellus and Ken, signing off.
MARCELLUS: Storm would be both
of our favorite characters.
KENNETH: That's because we
spend too much time together.
MARCELLUS: You love it.
KENNETH: I do, I do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]